hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks so much for being with us
Americans say no that's the focus of
tonight's
[Music]
angle this is what Americans are facing
this Christmas the cost of living in the
Biden economy is so high that more
people are raing their
401ks to pay their bills of course our
border total chaos 8 million migrants
from across the globe and Counting
including violent Criminal and
prospective terrorists the government
releasing 5,000 migrants into the
country every day with this really
stunned me
670,000 known goway in fiscal year 2023
alone now the open border has helped
sync our cities into squalor and has
deadly consequences in small town
America as well Rafael Goa Romero is now
behind bars in Jackson County charged
with capital murder and the death of
16-year-old Elizabeth Medina Edna police
say Romero is undocumented nobody ever
wants to see their child in a
bathtub the way I found
her the curtains were closed so I didn't
see her but when I open those
curtains students and I just want
Justice For My Baby murdered her left
her in the
bathtub if all that's not bad enough for
you there are new concerns that the tens
of thousands of Chinese Nationals mostly
young men lined up at the Border in
recent weeks you see the video could be
coming here to join sleeper cells to hit
our critical infrastructure more on this
later and I think the most heartbreaking
story of all this Christmas that more
Americans believe the American dream is
Out Of Reach even when you work hard and
do the right
thing this is the America that Joe Biden
and the globalists have created for us
spend us into Oblivion borrow and print
money like there's no tomorrow weaken
the dollar drive up inflation destroy
hopes for a better future oh and by the
way destroy public faith and
institutions like the doj and the FBI oh
and poison our kids yeah with radical
anti-American propaganda then divide the
country into pools of racial ethnic and
sexual victims and then when all that's
done expect those Americans to Rally
around the Ukrainian flag in order to
give them a better life
trust the same people who had usmed in
Iraq and Afghanistan and then boted the
withdrawal what vomir zalinsky Chuck
Schumer Mitch McConnell and Biden want
us to all believe is that if we don't
Pony up billions more to Ukraine all
hell will break loose and Vladimir Putin
will declare
Victory if we don't stop Putin it'll
endanger the freedom of everyone almost
everywhere Putin will keep going and
would be aggressors everywhere will be
emboldened to try to take what they can
by
force then it's a ground war right your
sons and your daughters their blood is
going to be spilled they're going to
die this was the message from the
Ukrainian president as well who met with
lawmakers and the president of the
United States in Washington
today and this entire sad Saga shows us
that once again 77 years after the end
of World War II Europe is still not
capable of or interested in defending
itself we're told that Ukraine's Freedom
depends entirely on the United States
borrowing billions more to keep them
fighting Russia and paying their
government
workers Fighting For Freedom we stand
firm no matter what Putin tries he
hasn't won any
victories Thomas Jefferson right well
there's nothing like having a foreign
leader travel here to demand more money
after he's failed to hit any Benchmark
of progress ress for which the original
funds were
appropriated but if you don't give him
more money right now you're going to
lose your entire
investment he's the Bernie madeof of
wartime
presidents what are we funding exactly
ever think about that his much Bley Hood
summer offensive was offensively
ineffective zilinski refuses to allow an
election next year how's that for
democracy he's declared martial law in
Ukraine he's banned the speaking of the
native language Russian of millions of
its own
citizens and who seen the top government
ministers in his own country embroiled
in major corruption scandals that
involve an obscene amount of money that
the US taxpayers have already given him
even the Ukrainian people see the
problem with billions in a floating
around in the hands of incompetent
zalinsky insiders an opinion poll
commissioned by Transparency
International found that 77% of
Ukrainian an see corruption as a major
concern another poll found that
ukrainians see corruption as a high
security threat get this even higher
than the threat of a nuclear strike by
Russia now if the grift and if the
corruption issue doesn't bother the
White House I guess that shouldn't
surprise any of us given what we know
about the greed and SLE of the Biden
family and while zalinski has taken some
modest steps we have to be fair to
address the corruption issue Americans
are so fed up they just want us to focus
on addressing on our own problems right
now that means problems here at home and
contrary to what President Biden said
late today at his press conference a
bipartisan majority does not any longer
support continuing the flow of money to
Ukraine a new CNN poll shows that
overall 55% say the US Congress should
not authorize additional funding to
support Ukraine versus 45% who say
congress should authorize such funding
and by the way 51% say that the US has
already done enough to help Ukraine 48%
say we should do
more but look we know this what the
American people want a strong border
strong industrial base Safe Streets High
educational standards none of it matters
to this white house instead they want to
cater to the needs of a country that is
not even a NATO
Ally I just signed another $200 million
draw down for the Department of Defense
for Ukraine and that'll be coming
Congress needs to pass a supplemental
funding to Ukraine before they break the
holiday recess before they give Putin
the greatest Christmas gift they could
possibly give
him but if Ukraine loses America will be
humiliated our Global status will be
diminished they say well I hate to break
it to all the globalists who were using
that old line but thanks to their
policies America already has been
diminished America already has been
humiliated we are in a state of Decline
and everyone knows it they spent the
last decade telling us that we were
systematically
racist how is that a country anyone
would want to emulate if that's all true
at this point I think China has to be
laughing Biden sucks UPS to X as X is
partnering with Putin and then America
goes into debt to help Ukraine beat
Putin can you explain that to me makes
zero sense our only hope is to rebuild
America that means manufacture things
here decouple from China grow our
economy cut government spending and
reform every major institution that has
failed to deliver wins and that includes
the Pentagon that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else